it's been a long time since i i used to
we used to work together no this is so
cool that was those were the good days
huh that was fun that was eons ago huh i
know it's what's eight years ago i
remember being i was in the not to bore
everybody but i was in the uh a
recording session for the simpsons when
i got the call to do this job and i
remember we were just about to record an
episode i got up and said see you suckas
and ran out the door yeah which was a
mistake i shouldn't have said that i was
like this show won't last long without
me
so 13 years doing bart it's hard to
believe because i i think so many of us
so rem we don't think of it as a show
that's been on that long right what are
your fa do you have a favorite favorite
lines i mean bart's had so many great
lines are there any that stick in your
head like oh totally well my favorite
one is hi i'm bart simpson who the hell
are you
kind of i gotta say i think i'm like
everybody else even though i work there
i never get over seeing the voice come
out of you i've just i don't i've never
gotten over that
yeah i think you and a lot of people it
still it still amazes me that people
don't know because i feel like i just
blah blah blah blah blah all the time
you know
do you ever just do that i mean if
someone's giving you a hard time you
know at an airport counter just suddenly
going to bart and like they would freak
them out wouldn't it
yeah but sometimes it comes in kind of
handy or could be entertaining you know
i kind of enjoyed doing that i you know
i went over to london recently and went
um i was on the plane and the
stewardess recognized my name and she
told me that the um the pilot was a huge
fan of the simpsons and he wanted to
meet me
i'm like okay so um i went up to the
cockpit and met him and met the other
the co-pilot and we you know he showed
me everything and that was fine and then
he said to me would you mind do you
think that if i introduced you you know
that you would do a little bot simpson
i said
okay okay i'm game so as we were landing
it was like 20 minutes into heathrow and
he said ladies and gentlemen i've got an
announcement to make we've got a special
guest on board nancy cartwright the boy
voice of bart simpson is here and i i so
uh i believe she's brought bot with her
i give you bought simpson i was like
ladies and gentlemen
i just want you to know that neither of
your pilots have been drinking this
entire flight
[Laughter]
the weather and heat throw is you know
seven degrees celsius i have no idea
what the hell that means but you know
we'll be landing in tokyo in about 20
seconds all right
i just want to say
i want to say
i want to say as a
as a passenger on that flight i'd be
worried
i'd be like they should concentrate why
are they screwing around with bart
simpson i don't think people know you
also do uh you do nelson the bullying
awesome right we hear a little now he's
got some great expressions like um the
thing about huckleberries is once you've
had fresh you'll never go back to canned
and you do rat you do ralph wiggum i do
ralph raphael
isn't that amazing
it tastes like burning
rock could say anything he could say
anything and get away with it you know
my catchphrase smells like cat food
[Laughter]
i'm doing kegels right now
it doesn't matter
[Applause]
you know what's funny is that you don't
see just on a human note you don't
people don't understand when you when
you work on the simpsons you're in a
room there's nobody else in there you
don't know what the response is it's
really nice to see you come out and just
do some of the voices and just see
people light up like that
it must feel good oh it's very cool yeah
because it's not a public venue you know
doing aspen and then going to london and
doing it you know having people see and
see their how happy this makes so many
people yeah i think so too i think you
have a clip here for us is that right oh
yeah um this this is from the episode
when bart gets famous okay and he said
now i know what you're doing he has a
special expression that he said i didn't
do it and uh
let's let's uh well this would be nice
to be a little weird let's take a look
at this clip from the simpsons
you know conan i have a lot to say
i'm not just a one-line wonder did you
know that a section of rainforest the
size of kansas is burned every single
just do the line
i didn't do it
great material we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
sit perfectly still only i may dance
my hair doesn't look like that
it's only right now i realize i have an
overbite uh
what is it and all the time that you've
been doing the show what's the weirdest
question from the media i just want to i
know you get a lot of weird questions
but before we go i just want to ask you
what's the weirdest question well it's
weird but it's like embarrassing but
it's happened twice is that somebody
actually had the nerve to ask me when
you're making love to your husband do
you like do bart's voice
i'm
sure
yeah i don't know
okay
uh you know you got a book out my life
as a ten-year-old boy is available uh
right now and of course like i have to
mention this the simpsons is on sunday
nights at 8 on fox so great to see you
again thanks so much for coming nancy
cartwright everybody we'll take a break
we'll be right back